the legendary fights of you and our two
of god
from [ __ ] carnage what do you call it
man four fights i mean well there's four
fights in three three those three fights
oh so yeah
three fights in 13 months
that's real fighting yeah it's real
fighting yeah yeah yeah it's a lot of
fighting that's a trick
you barely had a chance to train very
little time to train isn't that
something maybe a little tiny get out of
shape too yeah yeah
but jesus
maybe yeah maybe take like a week off
right and then back back at it and camp
yeah i think yeah
for that three period they fought more
than they trained huh probably yeah they
fought more than they trained
a lot has changed how have you seen the
boxing world right now coming together
making it like what's uh
what do you think about these boxers not
fighting each other i mean that's that's
the biggest
thing these guys what happened to the
fighter's eagle i mean my ego is too big
to have somebody else be champion i'm
cheating like i get into a fight with
him in the street i want those guys to
fight the guys
oh
god
jesus what round is that
oh no
my hips hurt the next day i said imagine
man
mike when he went down i'm saying to
myself don't get up
don't kill him no i'm saying please i
was saying the same [ __ ] stay down
and the guys were free and now they stop
that fight frank's like no no fight
ain't over
yeah what were you thinking that round
we got clocked a little what are you
thinking
i wasn't
what would happen mike was like i said i
was uh so dazed when i was against the
robes but but when he hit me
he woke me up
seriously like my legs were still gone
but my brain was like more i i knew
where i was where when i was days i was
like out of here that's the brush
and said that's what happened when they
fought
carmen basilio yeah he was pulling me
down to come
your brain and go back into like
your legs will still be gone but your
brain will be normal like you you know
where you're focused like it's crazy
yeah
but the thing is you just have to stay
there and take it and
try to fight it's for the same reason
why i think and i feel that box is more
dangerous than mma
because of the glove that you guys have
one a mma glove that has that's four
ounces will will knock you out like
quick yeah but with a boxing glove with
somebody that really knows how to
properly hit yeah how to hit you're
probably taking more
that may make up small he might get hit
hard and the fights a little bit shorter
but the the longer the fight
boxing you getting pounded pounded for a
longer 12 rounds and we're back at 15
back in years ago if you're we're boxing
15 round 12 round with those gloves
we'll break our hands
yeah no but the same thing you guys
would be knocking each other out within
a punch well listen yeah i think the
within the first round my hands would be
broken oh 100 did you break your hands a
lot mike when you're uh competing
fractured them a lot
should you ever fight with a broken hand
yeah you don't feel it the next day yeah
exactly and then i noticed this if you
have a bad head that's broken hit him to
the body it still hurts yeah i didn't
think it hurt because it only hurt me
but it still hurts when you punch him
through the body oh hitting the prayer
yeah if you have a broken hand he's
punched to the body the head's gonna
make smash your hand up and elbows go
right to the body you say it numbs up
yeah i broke my thumb and come off the
bone like that the tendon
you know and reno nevada i fought and uh
supposed to fight chavez that night yeah
chavez the shabbos got sick i saw me
they had to he pulled out or whatever
right in me so i fought as a mexican kid
from uh louis castillo for a month
from l.a man was he tough
and i calm in the second round what the
[ __ ] my that tendon snapped on my bone
but i fought with her because i didn't
feel it it went numb next morning but
then when i took it out that out of the
glove that night and night i had to get
it sewed back together like yeah did you
go to okay so you had to go under
surgery yeah they did like day surgery
and put it back together